[Música]
comenzamos reporteros de france 24
gracias por estar con nosotros la
historia de hoy es en francia- grupos de
ciudadanos comunes y corrientes de todas
las clases sociales y profesiones tienen
en común que quieren ayudar a los miles
de migrantes presentes en francia que
llegan de áfrica medio oriente europa
del este asia central y otros lugares
estos buenos samaritanos ayudan a
aquellos que quieren quedarse ya quienes
quieren cruzar el canal de la mancha
para ir a inglaterra conocimos a tres
familias que ayudan cada una a su manera
algunas van a los campos de migrantes y
otras aceptan acoger a los exiliados en
sus casas últimamente ha surgido un
movimiento de apoyo entre los
empresarios ante la falta de mano de
obra francesa quieren capacitar y
quedarse con los migrantes que se han
convertido en sus aprendices pero están
amenazados de ser expulsados del país
[Música]
estoy cansado hoy si se nota se nota
si yo también no tengo hambre no consigo
comer
pero necesito que aguante
no lo lograremos
ya ya está preocupado por patricia
durante los últimos seis días la
trabajadora agrícola al panadera no ha
comido nada sólo ha tomado café y té
sufre mareos y problemas de
concentración sienten mucha rabia ponga
que pero no tenía ganas de gritar solo
tenía ganas de mostrarme estado mental
que realmente quiero ayudar hay allá y
allá y no sabía qué otra cosa hacer a
patricia está en huelga de hambre lucha
para quedarse con su aprendiz ya ya
estamos en el apartamento de ain cerca
de lyon en la granja y verdad ya ya es
guinea no se encuentra en francia desde
los 16 años el estado se había hecho
cargo de él y estudiaba su futuro se
derrumbó al cumplir la mayoría de edad
se le dijo que debía abandonar el país y
se le prohibió continuar con sus
estudios es una situación complicada
para el negocio familiar ya que la
familia no puede encontrar un aprendiz
tuvimos unos cuantos jóvenes franceses
que llamaron a la puerta y se quedaron
unos cuantos días se fueron muy rápido
porque ese estilo de vida era muy duro
no estaban acostumbrados a vivir así
hay pocos candidatos porque las jornadas
de trabajo son largas a veces de 15 a 16
horas a lo largo de los meses ya haya
aprendido a hacer algunas tareas
agrícolas pero su actividad favorita es
la panadería y cortemos para hacer panes
de 500
ahora alistar la forma
tú sabes como henri pierre cumple
perfectamente el papel de profesor pero
en el fondo lo admite está al límite de
sus fuerzas
que le ayudemos como ya no sé cómo
decirlo se me caen las lágrimas
lo siento
no podemos entender por qué ponemos
barreras porque ponemos fronteras de
final porque rechazar hay allá que
alguien que quiere trabajar y lo único
que pide es a la pregunta cuál trip sé
qué poco ya está bien es dos días a la
semana a la casa de los que considera su
nueva familia cuatro años de convivencia
han creado fuertes vínculos como con
marc y la hija de patricia mi primer
recuerdo de ti es que no podías quedarte
quieto ahora te ves más calmado adelante
si vas de un lado a otro sin parar era
la época en la que talla aún creía que
todo saldría bien pero los dos últimos
años han sido mucho menos alegres desde
entonces he estado esperando solía venir
aquí los domingos y los lunes aprender
recetas aplicaba que hoy puedo decir que
me enseñaron bien y que puedo ayudarles
si la administración está de acuerdo
claro la administración donde lo dejo
ya ya encontró refugio en una comunidad
situada cerca de la granja a cambio de
su trabajo como voluntario recibe comida
y alojamiento mientras reciben noticias
sobre su estatus ya ya formó un
colectivo junto con varios jóvenes
migrantes en la misma situación al igual
que el mono y zaccaría también de guinea
no pudieron seguir estudiando desde que
cumplieron 18 años estudiamos tal y como
nos lo pidieron aprobamos los exámenes
capaces sacar ya también hizo su
formación profesional mayo tengo mi
diploma hice una formación profesional
aprendí francés de yamaha y nicky estoy
en una familia francesa que inició un
procedimiento de adopción a presión
hasta ahora sin resultados lo que quiero
decir es que tengo todo mi futuro aquí
en francia convención juvenil al igual
que todos los jóvenes de la asociación
animen a jesse ya habla poco de su
pasado antes de llegar a francia su
largo recorrido por el continente
africano vendido como esclavo en libia
rescatado en el mediterráneo con otros
migrantes y las razones por las que tuvo
que huir de su pueblo a los 14 años por
supuesta blasfemia contra el islam había
mucha violencia en la familia sobre todo
contra mí
se inventaron toda una historia de que
yo tenía algo en contra de la religión
para poner el pueblo en mi contra contra
la bendición y entonces tuve que salir
lo antes posible para salvar mi vida
porque además si no corría hacia el
riesgo de morir así por la lapidación
llame a la oficina de extranjería esta
mañana les pedí que por favor me
contestarán cuanto antes y principal del
rango del arco
porque esto no es ninguna broma no he
podido comer nada en los últimos siete
días es urgente
después de 15 días patricia perdió 7
kilos pero ganó la pelea la oficina de
extranjería de ain decidió concederle a
yaya el guineano el derecho a seguir con
sus estudios ya quedarse en francia
están destruyendo todo y repugnante kutz
los migrantes vienen aquí con
prácticamente nada y la policía destruye
lo poco que tienen tengan respeto tengan
humanidad an sophie y luego acaban de
recibir un vídeo que muestra la
evacuación de un campamento de
inmigrantes en hong sand a dónde se
dirigen en las afueras del campamento
situado en una zona boscosa los camiones
de la policía antidisturbios hacen
rondas
estamos llegando al campamento de ground
sans nos llevaremos a algunos chicos y
ellos tomarán lo que necesitan porque no
tenemos suficiente para todos
el bosque está ocupado por varios
centenares de emigrantes en su mayoría
kurdos de irak e irán todos ellos buscan
cruzar el canal de la mancha sobreviven
en condiciones difíciles a unos cientos
de metros de las primeras casas lo
gonzález a comprobar los daños la
operación policial ha terminado la zona
parece un inmenso basurero
allá hay una cubica limpia que fue
arrojada al agua algunos migrantes
siguen an sophie y luego hasta su auto
el baúl está lleno de abrigos pantalones
suéteres láminas de plástico financiados
por colectas en internet entre los
migrantes the groms and él varias
familias no está enfadado esta es la
segunda evacuación en una semana
destruir el refugio de un niño de gastar
sus juguetes en el barro aplastar sus
ropas desde brno no es para nada lógico
no conoce a sar y el iraquí y habla con
humor de los malos tratos que considera
que ha sufrido desde su llegada a europa
el pueblo francés es muy bueno pero la
policía no es buena
la política no nos cuenta que lleva dos
meses sin ver a su esposa y a su bebé
recién nacido
la familia había logrado entrar
clandestinamente en gran bretaña pero él
fue detenido y enviado a suecia dame tu
número uno anda no no duda en dar su
número de contacto
todos los migrantes lo guardan nos
ayudan mucho con las tiendas de campaña
las cobijas la comida por la noche hace
mucho frío en esta jungla no conlleva 25
años ayudando a los inmigrantes
para todas las semanas a los campamentos
pero sus acciones no siempre son bien
recibidas entre los habitantes
hay que tener cuidado donde se está hace
un año un hombre condujo tan cerca de mí
que me golpeó con su retrovisor abre de
son todos los racistas a quienes les
molesta que ayudemos a los exiliados
incluso en los días de la gran jungla me
perseguían en la autopista conducían muy
cerca y trataban de sacarme de la
carretera
luego lleva un año desempleado era
empleado de una empresa de limpieza
afirma haber sido despedido por ayudar a
los inmigrantes organiza sus actividades
en su casa por ejemplo hace braceros
para ayudarlos
a los mantienen calientes para que
puedan cocinar en buenas condiciones por
boncor por qué cocinar sobre un tronco
no es estable
es impuesto a gran comida se cae al
suelo a la lucha puntos ter
así es una típica noche en casa de la
uncaf viejo habla de los migrantes que
ha albergado aquí una pareja que logró
llegar a londres luego está casado y
tiene dos hijos de momento la familia
alberga a dos iraníes un padre y su hija
que desean permanecer en el anonimato
quieren encontrarse con su familia en
inglaterra
llegamos clandestinamente el camino fue
difícil muy estresante y niza
en croacia la policía nos trató muy mal
jorobas y estaba con otro migrante los
policías croatas nos golpearon y nos
robaron el dinero unam un pool la ropa
mobile alabama luego fuimos deportados a
bosnia
cinco meses antes la joven de 17 años
intentó cruzar el canal de la mancha con
contrabandistas a pocos kilómetros de la
costa su barco se volcó tuve problemas
de oído y el agua estaba muy fría
estaba muy asustado es que no quiero
volver a hacerlo
pero tengo que intentarlo además que le
voy a cerrar los ojos sabe nadar no no
sé nadar cuando era adolescente al ojo
le impactó ver grupos de inmigrantes
deambulando cerca de su casa desde
entonces ha trabajado duro para
ayudarlos en 2018 fue condenado a seis
meses de prisión condicional por ayudar
a tres iraníes a cruzar el canal de la
mancha les había comprado un barco de
segunda mano no se arrepiente de lo que
hizo
les di chalecos salvavidas gps tenían
una brújula bengalas de socorro tenían
todo lo que necesitaban y llegaron a
llegar
en 2020 10.000 inmigrantes intentaron
cruzar ilegalmente la costa francesa
hacia inglaterra 6 murieron 3
desaparecieron en el mar
mi primer día fue el peor el peor nunca
había hecho esto antes se levantaba por
la mañana no sabía cómo iba a lavarme
los dientes no sabía cómo iba a
encontrar un lugar donde comer solo
tenía un par de pantalones
no podía lavarlos porque si los lavaba
que me ponía nada
jacques diouf en parís el joven maliense
recuerda sus primeros meses viviendo en
una tienda de campaña en la calle como
estos migrantes lo llamaremos sal y un
nombre falso en cualquier momento el
estado puede decidir expulsarlo según
sus documentos tenía 15 años cuando
llegó a francia para salir de la calle
alí intentó hacer valer su minoría de
edad en vano dijo que no creía que yo
fuera menor de edad que te pareció
extraño tengo todos los papeles de mi
país mi pasaporte tengo todo conozco a
muchos jóvenes que están en las calles
como yo tres años después de su llegada
a francia ally sigue sin tener permiso
de residencia oficial pero entre los
jóvenes migrantes es ahora uno de los
afortunados ya que tiene una pequeña
habitación para el solo que si se movió
este es mi escritorio
es donde hago mis deberes después de la
escuela
si pongo mis cosas aquí pongo mi mochila
aquí y mi ropa
jennifer está cambiando
así y haya una ventana de un dibujo
no está muy organizado
un joven como los otros que arribamos la
pared de la lavandería aquí así que ya
no tenemos un lavadero le hicimos un
espacio para que tenga su privacidad
simití allí vive en este apartamento
parisino desde hace año y medio con
nahuel asís y sus hijos el joven tiene
su propia llave comparte las comidas y
su tiempo libre con la familia que pizza
quieres la de cuatro quesos o la de
cuatro quesos
la abuela es abogada
así es conductor de tren con movidos por
la situación de los menores sin hogar la
pareja decidió ayudar la asociación los
puso en contacto con alí e incluso vimos
a mujeres solteras que acogían a jóvenes
así que es tranquilizador ver la
experiencia de otras personas que decían
que tenían miedo de albergar personas al
principio y que al final todo salió bien
en lugar de dormir afuera
tengo al menos a uno de estos jóvenes el
adolescente tardó una semana en sonreír
por primera vez algunos meses después de
su llegada el hijo
de la familia nació y allí celebró su
cumpleaños 18 con ellos
estas personas son más bien tímidas al
principio nunca soledad antes de
implicarse en la vida familiar tienden a
observarlo todo y hacer preguntas al
boxeo después de que si no hay ninguna
molestia en siempre donde once nuevos
fue antes de utilizar una habitación de
la casa preguntan dónde se integran
fácilmente en la vida familiar poco a
poco no soy yo no soy el hombre del fin
no soy así dice que considera a alí como
su propio hijo joven va a la escuela y
participa en una actividad de ayuda a la
comunidad repartir alimentos a los
necesitados qué es esto tortilla papas
papas tortillas tienes una bolsa
plástica que puedes ponerla en una bolsa
plástica hay se resumieron las bolsas al
y siempre asiste a estas formas del 11
23 veces inm después le dije sede
contáctame siempre que reparte alimentos
como proveedor de alojamiento a menores
ha estado solidario con los pobres
barrio así es dedica mucha energía a
ayudar al prójimo se niega a que su
comportamiento se considere fuera de lo
normal yo me considero un buen
samaritano me siento mal y creo que como
ser humano recibimos y debemos es un
símbolo de la solidaridad y colaboración
que debemos tener como seres y la
sonrisa desfile como imagen ahora que es
mayor de edad el futuro de alí dependerá
de sus próximas citas en la oficina de
extranjería y de la buena voluntad de la
administración
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 y habernos acompañado en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web más 24
punto com para ver esta emisión y las
antillas hasta la próxima semana
[Música]